horror fans have a lot to look forward
to over the next couple of years with a
growing slate of sequels to smash heads
original projects from trusted
filmmakers and even a couple of exciting
remakes on the rise 2019 in particular
looks to be a strong year for the genre
so let's take a look at what the kind of
distant future will bring for fight fans
an American Werewolf in London John
Landis is landmark 1981 film established
him as a daring filmmaker with a strong
visual style and proved that he could
successfully blend two gut-wrenching
horror with comedy
so remaking an American Werewolf in
London might seem like a risky
proposition for most filmmakers but with
the original or - a son Max is ready to
take on the task and he has his father's
blessing sort of the older Landis told
Collider I know it won't be as bad as an
American Werewolf in Paris which was oh
he's serious would you fire starter
Stephen King's firestarter a story about
a young girl with powerful pyrokinetic
abilities on the run from sinister
government agents was adapted in 1984
with a young drew Barrymore in the lead
while it's one of the more faithful
adaptations of King's work it hasn't
aged perfectly so Blum House productions
has ready to give the story a fresh new
look
one potential hiccup is a screenwriter
Akiva Goldsman is attached to direct
Goldsman had a pretty major setback in
2017 with his screenplay for King's Dark
Tower failed to resonate with fans but
maybe he'll turn things around with the
new firestarter it's chapter 2 an even
stronger Stephen King story in the
pipeline is a sequel to it the first
chapter blew everyone away at the box
office but Warner Brothers didn't
greenlight the second installment until
they were absolutely sure the film would
be a hit which means even though fans
are clamoring for a follow up there's
still a lot of work to be done
director and the Meuse Ciotti is all but
guaranteed to return and say that the
film will center around the adult lives
of the losers as they return to Derry to
battle penny wise but that we can expect
to see all of those cute kiddos from the
first film - it's chapter 2 is scheduled
to hit theaters on September 6 2019 The
Crooked Man in addition to a new
installment of the conjuring 2019 will
also deliver another spin-off slash
sequel in The Crooked Man based on one
of the creepiest scenes from the
conjuring
- the film is expected to flesh out the
crooked man's backstory between this the
nun and the continued chills brought on
by the Annabelle series the conjuring
universe is expanding into even scarier
new territory with every take entitled
Wizard of Oz movie the Wicked Witch of
the West is pretty frightening and
goodness knows the world of elf frank
baum got wild in return to us but now a
new line cinema is ready to see Oscar
even darker with a Wizard of Oz centric
horror film the film will be written by
newcomer Mike ways who's already showed
some promise in Hollywood with a
blacklist script called hammer space
with all the anthropomorphic creatures
and conniving Wizards already lurking
around us it's not hard to imagine the
world getting very very grim and titled
joss whedon world war ii film just
Whedon has been fired up to the realm of
superheroes lately but he still got the
gift of making edgy horror fare in 2019
he's returning to the fight fold at last
with a new historical horror film he
told complex it's as dark as anything
I've ever written it's a historical
fiction / horror movie about a time when
the world was going insane Whedon went
on to discuss the eerie parallels he
uncovered between 1932 termini and the
modern-day United States so counts on
this one to be creepy and a little too
timely for comfort The Blob of the 1958
low-budget horror classic The Blob has
already gotten the remake treatment once
in 1988 that version was pretty in
essential but with samuel l.jackson and
Halle Berry reportedly starring in a new
take things are about to get even
quirkier action director Simon West has
long been attached to the project but
we'll have to wait to see how the blob
takes shape but with jackson on board to
star we can probably count on some
wonderfully weird one-liners
with these snakes on this mother goodbye
glass if you haven't seen split yet
spoiler alert
you may want to skip ahead still there
okay split was certainly anchored by
James McAvoy's mesmerizing performance
but it's the film's last act that really
sticks the landing
in the final scene Bruce Willis makes an
unexpected return as David Dunn the hero
of to thousands of breakable and ties
the world of the beast into the world of
Samuel o jackson's mr. glass and my
Shyamalan has never been a sequel guy so
it was a shock to see that those two
films are not only connected but that
our third installment of the unbreakable
series called glasses on the way to the
cast will feature Willis Jackson McAvoy
and Anya Taylor joy or reprising their
roles and it will be the final
installment of the dark superhero
trilogy that has suddenly taken shape
glass will hit theaters on January 18th
2019 eli writer david chatter ello
contributed one of the most brutally
satisfying segments of the 2014 horror
anthology ABCs of death - and his
screenplay for Eli garnered some
attention after making the 2015
blacklist
the film centers on a sick boy who
experiences ghostly goings-on at a
secluded clinic and was sinister to
scare and foia at the helm Eli could be
a sleeper hit in the making
Hellboy fans have long held out hope for
a third installment of director
Guillermo del Toro's Hellboy series but
that hope was unfortunately dashed when
del Toro finally admitted in 2017 that
it just wasn't going to happen
but that doesn't mean moviegoers have
seen the last of the right hand of doom
director neo marshal best known for his
nerve jangling 2005 thriller that
descent will be taking the helm of the
r-rated reboots and stranger things as
David Harbour has already impressed with
her first glimpse of his physique for
the title role count on having a hell of
a good time when Hellboy hits theaters
on January 11th entitled Jordan Peele
project last but not least Jordan Peele
is returning to the horror scene in 2019
his directorial debut gets out was one
of the most talked about movies of 2017
so there's a lot of excitement already
building around what he may do next Pele
is expected to deliver another socially
charged horror film and told screen
junkies the worst monster that you can
explore in a horror movie as human
beings themselves I think the scariest
thing we don't talk about enough is that
when people get together with capable of
the darkest things peels new pick will
drop on March 15th 2019 thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your loved team
[Music]